I'm scanda and I worked on for my super
yard project a more secure way of doing
biometric evaluation so currently
biometrics are alternative password
that's often more secure and more
convenient however they're often
insecure and modern implementations
because what you can do is what's called
side-channel attacks are their memory
probing attacks and so what this does is
extract the plaintext model out of
memory and then replay that onto the
system and by this way gain in
legitimate access to the system so what
the solution to this is to actually
encrypt the model in memory and so for
if you have an encrypted model in memory
I speak into it and does all the
evaluation on that model from my voice
and the model in the encrypted domain
and so I developed as a speaker
recognition model that it's able to
evaluate whether an input is whether the
speaker's a valid speaker or not valid
speaker based on does all the
computations in the encrypted domain and
so we my mentor and I designed these set
of protocols that do everything in the
crypto domain as well as the Gaussian
mixture models that actually do the
speaker recognition and so we found that
their accuracies were comparable to
modern state-of-the-art but it's still
doing everything in the encrypted domain